hey guys it's Kayla back with another
video so the topic of today's video is
being yourself being yourself can be
hard and it's like aren't I always being
myself and yeah for sure
but being yourself is like not changing
yourself to impress someone else a lot
of people like call me quiet or shy or
whatever
but I'm not quiet most quiet Kayla day I
don't talk a lot at school but if people
talk to me and stuff they'd find out
that I'm like really funny and cool and
talking by the way I like your shirt a
lot it's like so cool
[Music]
[Music]
I said one more week of eighth-grade
right yeah that's crazy yeah uh-huh okay
so growing up can be a little bit scary
and weird we will begin to explore these
changing bodies of yours it's gonna be
make sure to share it and subscribe to
my channel
gucchi I think you're so cool maybe you
just need to put yourself out there a
little I'm gonna stop you say one thing
I'm really like nervous over time try
really hard not to feel that way but you
just need to face your fears
and black people know they're really
[Music]
just grab my phone how to charge it yeah
I mean if he sometimes died charging at
you but my my phone I just cuz things
are happening right now doesn't mean
they're always cannot happen
who's in there just sort of my hopes and
dreams right I was a complete bathroom
when I was your age
really eighth grade is Bill worse you
never know what's next and that's what
makes things exciting scary
and fun
when did you get snapchat we're good
this screen is great
[Music]
you